allow me to introduce uh the next
keynote session for you um the session
that will end this day with a big uh
smiling face I'm introducing to you the
hugging face team um and we will have
the co-founder of hugging face on stage
Thomas wolf and he's not alone he
brought his team his Amsterdam based
team actually so that's really great um
and while I think they don't really need
an introduction
let me give a few words I think when we
were selecting keynote speakers we're
looking for very relevant topics and
inspiring people right and they will be
talking about training large language
models well undeniably relevant at this
point uh as organizers we even needed to
make sure not to create an conference
about llms this is how many proposals uh
we got and everyone is talking about the
hugging F face tools that they use for
their
projects and um inspiring I mean hugging
face is open sourcing the transformance
and data sets that we can all use here
and we have the co-founder or the
initiator on stage here so pretty
inspiring to me um happy to have you all
please welcome to the stage Thomas and
Julian G and
alesandro think just send can you hear
me yeah okay great well I'm very honored
to be here thanks a lot Sophie for the
introduction uh very happy to be here
with with the team J alandro G uh so if
you've been following a bit the news in
the AI world I mean the the research
news you probably saw there was a new
Falcon model that's the new biggest open
source model so they're the one who
trained this model uh props to them
congratulations and uh actually uh I
decided that uh because we are in
Amsterdam uh and they there we we
actually talk about that so you will
have actually presentation on what is
maybe the hottest model today or at
least last week was the hottest model
and uh and we'll uh split the
presentation in two I'll first present
the whole Ugg face ecosystem uh with a
very wide overview and then we'll do
this very uh researchy Focus uh
aspect um so uh let's get started
I start with a little bit of History to
tell you why we're here today while we
talking about AI so uh I think it
started about 12 years ago if we have to
start it when software started to uh eat
the world the famous uh sentence by by
Anderson orovitz which has proven very
true I would say um and I was the first
I would say a huge uh technology shift
bring brought by Hightech right right um
the second one started kind
of maybe maybe less visible in the
beginning 2017 we started to have deep
learning that uh that was working for
the first time uh like new network were
actually getting better than all the
Technologies right and um we had this
very Visionary uh post by kaati saying
that deep learning was going to eat
software and bring a software 2.0 where
we would not program stuff but we would
just put data in a black box well it was
just only the the second uh phase of
eating because now uh last year we say
Transformers have started to eat deep
learning so what are Transformers they
are this very versatile architecture
that can be applied to actually any type
of data almost well there probably there
was probably at P data a lot of
discussion around is it working in all
case in many case it's also still not
working but definitely Transformers are
what is pouring CH GPT they are also
what is pouring now like uh the the the
sound generation uh things and like
basically a lot of things is getting
focused on this
architecture and a much more closest to
us I would say is now the advance of
what people are calling generative AI
which is
basically the uh realization of this
idea that we just put data in a model
and we'll see what it gives and it's
actually giving very interesting things
um now generative AI is hungry that
sounds dangerous and we I think are
today at maybe a key point in uh history
of ml machine learning well there's a
couple of things one thing is that for
the first time well I guess here a lot
of people are software Engineers but for
the first time this technology is now
being used mostly by people who are not
software Engineers or ml Engineers well
just a few years or maybe I would I
would may be there to say just one year
ago it was mostly a subset of software
engineer like people who knew both how
to code and also how to tray model that
was using them and today basically
anyone uh my mother is asking me
question about J GPT and she's not a
software engineer um so there is this
huge turning point and we also at a
crossroad specifically uh for hugging
face I would say but also here for pataa
which is a I think the home of Open
Source uh software right and we have we
have a choice now between two futures
we can say uh this new software these
new models they're actually just an
extension of software and they should
also be open source right they should
also be open that would be better for
everyone because everyone can contribute
all of you could like help develop model
um but there's a lot of other people who
think maybe they should not be open
source maybe there should be like here a
stop where software might be open source
but ml model the software 2.0 should not
be open source these are huge debate um
also internet at hugging face so hugging
face I'll show you we we are I would say
maybe a little bit like um neutral
platform here so for instance we host a
lot of Open Source model on the Hub but
uh little people know that actually
majority of the model on the Hub are
private like two3 of the model on the
Hub are private so we kind of see both
side and I would say both side have
advantages and U
drawbacks uh I can of summarize the a
couple of them here well the most
Salient right if we go to a future where
we closely control every model it might
be better for security for risk people
are talking a lot about misuse of model
right like adapting model people are
also talking a lot about model getting
Rogue so Terminator like thing um I
personally don't really believe in that
but uh and I would say it's maybe even a
matter of believing or not sometime it's
almost Ault um but yeah there's
definitely some question and one
question is also uh the business model
right if you give everything for free if
you try model and give them for free how
do you make money so that's a big
question um another thing is let's say
okay we we have no problem with business
model we're not scared about these
models uh and um we look at open source
then I think there's a lot of
interesting thing right the the thing
I'm most excited about is that we can
build some AI just like the open-source
software that we use something that's
kind of close to a common good for
Humanity basically I think sometime well
sometime we annoy that the library we
use but I still can see them as a common
good for everyone like everyone can use
them everyone can access them if there's
a bug you're noed about you can fix it I
think it's a beautiful thing that
software brought to humanity and that
would be very nice to seea like this but
then there's a lot of other question if
you want to dive in this uh that's
that's a lot of the things we do at hug
face which is try to think about all
this question this problem so that's the
very big picture but I want to dive a
bit more in uh um like practical thing
today and this is basically what we're
going to talk about uh it's six six step
but basically they will go quite fast
I'll talk about the Hub of hugging face
if you don't know about it I'll talk
about the challenges about inference and
training demos and then we'll talk about
research so model data why did we build
hugging phase um well we build it
because I think it's very nice if we
share all these artifacts and the
specificity of this new Revolution of
the software 2.0 is that is not only
about code so there are code Bay but
there is a lot of other artifacts that
we didn't use to uh to have before and
one of them is models model has usually
quite heavy you know data uh Focus um
files and they they can be difficult to
host they can be difficult to share so
that's why we build it data set are
something that are slightly um more
common I would say that's why Pi data is
called Pi data and something new that
we're also hosting and sharing on the
Huggy face Hub are spaces which is a
kind of a demo basically the ID is uh if
you have a model it's nice if you can
interact with it very easily it's even
better um and that's actually what we s
what we see in practice so here I show
you the numbers on the Hub they're
actually slightly slightly old because
it's really growing exponentially this
was over the first six months of the
year we we get three times more models
hosted on the Hub like maybe five times
more data set and the spaces it's almost
like it's almost five times so spaces
and demo are growing incredibly and
that's kind of linked to the fact that
you know a lot of people now using this
model are not anymore software engineer
but they're kind of anyone
actually the model Hub is a place
basically where you can share your model
your data set your demo we try to push a
lot for Best Practices we think a good
way to uh have what I was saying like
this you know common good for Humanity
is to push for good practices which are
in our case like nice versioning like
saving gated access maybe controlling
how you want to diffuse your model maybe
better documentation around you know
what did you put in your model what type
of data and all these things and our
idea is if you have a nice place for
that if you try to push people in doing
that they actually will want to do that
and have a nice uh way to share the
model with like ethical responsible
practices basically that's also why we
have a community discussion
Pages now let's say you've chosen your
find your model and you you want to try
it uh you need to use it inference
there's a couple of big challenges with
regard to like how we did software
before and they're related to what I was
saying which is this model are huge
usually um they're also very hard to
evaluate having good Benchmark you know
is is very tricky and I think we're
still like learning a lot on this you
really want to tailor them for your use
case but how do you do that right you
can't just change lines of code so
there's a couple of like thing that are
very difficult to to do and so we've
started to dive in this with what we
what we like to do which is a
combination of a set of Open Source
Library uh focusing on some problems so
problem one problem is for instance they
are too big okay let's quantize them
instead of having them in 32 bites let's
have them in four bytes or eight bytes
that's the library bytes and bytes bits
and bytes uh and that basically lets you
run huge model now on your laptop almost
you can you can run that's really crazy
and the future I see is a future where
this
model will actually be you know just
running on any any type of consumer
Hardware um it can be difficult to like
uh replicate them or to make them run
with batch inference fast and so we have
a set of Library accelerate and text
generation inference that are there to
to solve these type of of
problems Tech generation inference in
particular is a library I I like a lot
uh in part because it's coded in Rust
behind and it's kind of nice but also
because it Implement all the good
practic that you will want usually when
you use this model you want to deploy
them on S GPU you want to be able to
stream your token at them not to have to
to do some complex batching and
basically has all this all the thing in
it so it's a very nice one now let's say
you want to adapt your model to your use
case okay you've find your nice model
you know how to use it but now it's not
exactly what you would like to do you
would like to generate poem about you
know the shipyard that are now
reconverted in Conference Centers and
Lama model does not really know how to
do that um it can be tricky because
basically if you just go from the for
the simple you know training activ model
are really huge so for instance right
now while I'm talking I just started a
run on fine tuning this very large
Falcon model and I need uh I need 64 GPU
for instance and that's very small
actually in the best case I would like
to have 128 GPU to train it so that's
that's a lot of money that's a lot of
GPU and so what we've developed recently
uh is also a new library again to solve
this which is called PFT uh and the idea
here is that you don't need to find an
old the model you can add just a little
bit slight tiny layers of parameters
that you will adapt and you train just
these models just this just these tiny
layers it's called loraa or PFT and with
these things you can actually fine tune
like a huge model like the 65b Lama one
the largest one and just a single GPU so
that's also what I was saying this is
coming to like consumer Hardware this is
also one of the technique that make this
possible if you combine that with
conation like a set of things you
actually now can do a lot with these
very large models just one example
whisper right is this model uh that let
you transcribe audio in
text it's a quite a large model but with
Laura you just find you one% of the
parameter if you want to adapt it to
your use case and it can just work on a
8 GB GP U which is really small
activ uh these are other example you can
use this stable diffusion is mod WR that
take text and generate image you can add
adapters and here you find you need to
kind of learn some type of Concepts if
you want in the adapters like the
concept of a dog or a toy and then you
can reuse and share and that's kind of a
funny new thing where you actually reuse
it's it's a little bit like a piece of
code you will share your adapter which
is just a matrix but basically there is
some functionality uncoded in it there's
a lot of like new use case that we're
starting to think about which are very
interesting and here with like Laura we
see the community a lot of people
training adapters and sharing them which
is very
funny okay now let's say you've select
your model you've deployed it you've
adapted it and you want to have other
people use it you want to showcase
it here you you will want to spin up a
space on hugging face why well well also
I I do that because that's hugging face
so I like to use my oun tools that dog
footing but it's also a very nice thing
actually gradio is very easy to spin up
and the idea is a lot of the time you
know this model they have predefined
type of inputs predefined type of
outputs and we know you know what they
expect they expect text they output text
for instance so we can just plug like
pretty pre-made you know interface to
the input to the output and actually
this can be very easy to to make a model
uh in a interactive
setting so uh that's I think one of the
reason we' see a huge grow there was a
lot of virality last year when we
started to have spaces in particular
around uh image text to image right on
the on the right was Del M Min I don't
know if you remember for last summer it
became viral you know it was like just
made by uh one guy Boris in Texas just
training at D mil and it would it was
able to generate so funny images that
became really huge and recently uh in
the past few few months there was the
state stable diffusion uh various model
that they train that also became really
huge now typically as I was saying
telling you making a gradio interface
and basically building a gradio space to
interact with your model is just like
three lines that's super super quick to
do you just explain basically what type
of input what type of output if you want
you can organize that a bit on the page
if you don't want you don't need to and
then you run it and we what we do at Hy
face is basically we give you compute
free compute for that
it's a little secret actually is that
you can use spaces to do many things so
I use them to do pretty much everything
when I want to have people interacted
with them and something that was also uh
very viral around spaces this summer was
uh leaderboard because one of the big
problem when you start to have like we
have now a million repository on the Hub
is how do you find the model that you
want to use right how do you know and so
uh it's related to the difficulty to
evaluate this model it's also very hard
to to evaluate them and so we've studied
a little bit to make a small leader
board on that actually for our internal
use case if you look at the organization
there hug face H4 is our internal
research team studying rhf and they just
made this small space and it became
viral and huge and so I think the the
idea now for us is to start to build
this and to maybe make more leaderboards
maybe make more evaluation of the all
the models in the hub because there is
clearly a lot of people who would like
to know more about you know metric and
have more matrics on this model so
that's just the beginning right now we
have four uh Benchmark uh but just this
week we were thinking about extending it
to seven and trying to cover more and
more of the capabilities of the
model now I want to talk very briefly
about open research because then I'll be
a bit longer right I just go over to say
that uh in addition to the software that
we do we like to organize very large
research research project and I just
show you two of them one was kind of
maybe a few years ago now three years
ago was big science and here the idea
was okay all these model are usually
trained with very small team in just one
company that's a bit boring what about
you know trying to train all together a
bit like City at home we all looking for
aliens maybe we find two of them in
Mexico yesterday I think but yeah we all
looking for aliot maybe we could also
train models together and so uh we say
okay uh we're going to find way to comp
to to get some comput and then we just
invite everyone to come to come try
model so we end up being like a thousand
researchers including actually some of
you J was there uh maybe that was before
maybe yeah uh and we trained one model
Bloom that was the first mtil world
model that came just after gpt3 so
that's kind of old now I would say uh
but it was a very nice model it was the
first one that covers so many languages
and it's actually still very interesting
uh there was this uh study published
this summer by Stanford which was taking
all the new regulation that are coming
in AI you know there is one big
regulation in Europe that are that is
being discussed there is one big
regulation in the US that are being
discussed and people talk a lot about
okay open source like uh right to uh of
data access and how and how we should
how we should regulate them that and
when you take all the proposal that are
uh in Europe today the model that we
that we made you know in in this kind of
Community Way was by far the one that
filled the that uh checked the most
boxes in the regulation I would dare to
say that's probably the only one that
would have been accepted today as a
model and the other one are basically CH
GPT and and bench of model they are not
all Clos toce L is also open source GPT
noo X um but that's very interesting I
think as a way to to think about this
these
questions inspired by uh by big science
that was very very nice but also
slightly too big to be honest a th000
researcher a th people training one
model is is a lot we've started a second
project called bigod with actually
people here so big Cod is a is is also a
fairly large project now with 500
participants and is mostly lead being
led by by Huggy face two people and two
people here in Amsterdam har from
service now uh who are also co-leading
us lead with us and it followed the
recipe of big science with some learning
so first created a data set called the
stack and we tried to focus on something
a bit more narrow which is code
generation models so like think about
co-pilot this type of thing they're very
interesting they have the same problem
as gpt3 at the time they're all closed
tools they're all private we have no
idea how they train and so the idea was
here again let's try to do something in
the open let's aim to to make a nice
code completion model and to make it
open
transparent um so we started by making a
data set that's already been used
actually a lot um and then we train a
model just before the summer called star
coder there uh we thought a little bit
about what people want they want model
that go fast that are small that are
very good that have long Co but they
want everything so we try to put
everything uh it kind of succeeded so we
had a uh that was in May that we relas
the models that was the best open source
model on a on a set of
evaluation and uh I think it was a very
first uh first try at this now we're
trying to train the second one just as
I'm talking we're very excited about
this this as well and you can see the
power of making something open source is
that the data set and the model that
were shared they have always been using
countless things you know and it was
just released in May so may that's like
four months ago we already have like
three at least three but maybe more if
you saw yesterday there was a a model
called uh fee 1.5 by Microsoft super
interesting it's also training on the
stack in part so like all the thing you
release like this they create huge
ecosystem of people reusing them you
know fine tuning model and everything so
that's super interesting to do this type
of
calization and now uh let uh
julan continue if a focus on data yes um
hi everyone so for the remaining of the
presentation I'm going to talk about
some work we did in the scope of the
Falcon models along with G and Alexandro
and some other members of the team as
well who are not here today um and
essentially this work is about finding
data at scale for large language model
so you probably heard that large
language model quite an appetite for
data and absolutely tremendous
quantities and early on when we started
the Falcon project like bit a year ago
about that or year and a half um we
essentially realized that yes the amount
of data we would need uh would be like
tremendous like trillions of tokens or
trillions of wordss essentially um and
kind of this is kind of relating a bit
like the story of us going uh through
different ideas to fulfill that needs um
so
one of the key idea that you find uh in
classic large language model literature
is that you are essentially your data
set is made of two things so a good part
of it is made of web data um the idea is
that you need so much data that at some
point you need some bulk data data that
you can get in lot and the rest uh is
made of like high quality corpora that
you are selecting so this might be books
or like technical papers or that kind of
things um and you know if you go through
an history of large models you know for
gpt3 they had about 300 billion tokens
if you want to convert in world you can
more or less divide by 1.5 or two it
depends a bit on the tokenizer and you
know for gpt3 for instance uh you had
about 40% of the data that was coming
from what we call curated sources so
once again these books technical paper
that kind of thing um then you know you
had this open source actually well open
data set called the pile which was kind
of a reproduction of the gpt3 data that
was made by a collective called a lat Ai
and which has been used massively in the
past few years in a lot of open llms and
the pile you know want up to 80%
curation and you have other like
state-of-the-art model you know from
Deep Mind from Google uh who essentially
had a lot of curated data once again
kind of kept that fraction very high um
the difficulty is that getting that
curated data is very hard each
individual sources you know each like
source of a technical paper of a book
requires you to do manual work you know
to get it and the pipeline that you
build you know to get uh to get for
instance paper from archive maybe you
can reuse some part to get papers from
PubMed but only part of it so you end up
doing a lot of duplicate work and this
is not super scalable um and as you know
like the needs of like large language
model training are growing uh into
trillions and trillions of token these
become very challenging to accommodate
um and but the C is that you know you
will be like oh why don't just go with
web data you know like full web data
after all if we already put a fraction
of it why not do that so here I'm
putting some results actually from big
science which Tom was talking just about
about data quality and the impact it has
on the performance of the model um and
one thing that's very interesting to see
is this idea that first you the model
from open AI when you evaluate them
through the API um actually outperform
significantly uh even stain on the pile
you know which was supposed to be kind
of inspired by the data of open a so
open source reproduction that failed at
making essentially data of the same
caliber than the one open was training
on at the time and these numbers you
know you see the difference of two% this
is actually very significant um I come
to this on the next one but essentially
a difference of 2% can account for like
a change in scale you know how much
comput you are putting into your model
of like two or 3x so imagine instead of
spending like you go instead of doubling
or tripling your GPU budget you could
simply improve your data processing and
obviously data processing is much much
cheaper than training models you know
for training the models you are going to
put thousands of gpus together uh GPU
computes is much much more expensive
than CPU comput in fact you know in
thata in the data pipelines we have
developed we have run on CPU cluster
with like 10,000 or 20 20,000 cores but
that is still a fraction of the cost of
running you know on the large GPU
cluster so essentially data is a
multiplier of your efforts you can do a
lot of efforts on this that Downstream
uh will save you compute and allow you
to be more efficient in your model um
and this really I like the issue with
quality and that issue with quality
people have been linking it to this idea
of curated data essentially they have
been thinking oh you know and it's kind
of like you know I think it will be the
a prior idea that we would all have in
this room of like you know maybe if I
curate the data if I put s is like
probably a technical paper from archive
is bringing more value to the model than
just some random web page that I have
that I have crawled um and so people
were strongly believing that you know if
we want to scale the data we also have
to scale the curated
sources um but this is where it kind of
all breaks down um historically speaking
you know if you look at gpt3 people like
open a TR 175 billion parameter model on
about 300 billion tokens so about 100
200 billion WS but actually if you are
looking at like modern practices in
models we have tend to keep the model
the same size but train them for longer
and the main reason this is because you
want to serve as small of a model as
possible because the larger the model
you are serving the more expensive it is
to serve and then you know your Ops
people are going against you and telling
you why is it so big this is a pain to
deal with um so people instead you know
to kind of decouple the compute that you
are spending in training and in
inference you train for longer and then
you have a model at the end of the same
size so easier to serve a smaller one
than the larger model and if you look at
modern practices you would have to train
such a model on 3.5 trillion token which
is a tremendous amount uh of data um and
well this is actually this is a specs
for the training of Falcon 1B it's one
it's a bit more parameters it's 180
billion parameters on 3.5 trillion token
of data so the question becomes where do
you find that much data because this is
an impressively large amount actually
you know if you look even at the
literature for large language model open
like in in papers there is no data set
that was reported until a month ago that
was this big like the largest one were
reported like a trillion trillion half
then Lama 2 two trillion and then what
we did actually refine web in total the
full data set we got is about 5 trillion
uh so this is like a really unique scale
when we stared at this a year ago this
was uh a really frightening scale um and
essentially you have two approach the
first approach uh is kind of the naive
approach which uh people in deep
learning have really enjoyed in the past
which is simply upsampling you know just
repeat the data repeat the sources um
most llms already do this they upsample
their equality sources by one or three
time the problem for us is that if we do
this on like common data sets we will
have to upsample by 10x and so this will
lead to some problem down the line
what's nice about upsampling you know is
like kind of we think some of the corpor
high quality that we can use and
probably and this is more of a technical
remark but maybe you can sustain
multiple epochs on llm there is some
results for this however the issue is
that data duplication and memorization
are very scary at scale essentially the
larger the model the more it will have a
tendency to memorize and memorization of
the data sample obviously is an issue
for dstream use but also is an issue in
terms just of the performance of the
model essentially it diminishes quite a
bit the performance of the the model the
model kind of choose to memorize at the
expense of generalizing as a very broad
idea this is actually a bit more complex
uh but yeah and you know when we did
this now there is work that shows that
probably doing two to four EPO so two to
four repetition is fine when we did this
this work wasn't there yet so we
essentially were quite scared by this
what you could do instead is scale web
data so we are already using a lot of
web data in our large language models um
if you look at common call so common
call is this um is an open initiative
from a foundation that craws the web and
make it available to everyone you know
like doing crawling at web scale is very
expensive why duplicate efforts so this
Foundation essentially do it for most of
the community and then you can just
download it and use it um there is about
100 to 150 trillion tokens in common
call so this is plenty enough on paper
um what's nice with scaling web data is
that it's very scalable you know before
I was telling you curated sources it's
annoying you have to work through each
one of them individually if you get an
improvement for web data you get it for
all of it so it's like a massive
leverage that you have every hour of
engineering that you spend every line of
code that you right has tremendously
more leverage because it's going to
impact you know amounts of data that are
incredible down down the line um there
is also I put this as a maybe I'm not a
lawyer you should not be taking my
advice as legal advice it's probable
that this kind of data has less legal
issues um if you go and take and
straight up get books from libgen there
is a much stronger case against you in
Court than if you are just you know
crawling web data that is publicly
available um and this also leads to this
consideration that web data is probably
a bit more uh it bit nicer in this way
however the big caveats and I think this
is something you can kind of all guess
is that out of the box web data is
absolutely atrocious uh if you open a
dump from common craw out of the box the
likelihood that you will find something
that is incredibly bad is about 90 like
it's about you know 70 to 90% and you
will see the exact numbers in the
pipeline before I'm not really making
them up so it's like every every bad
thing you can imagine you know
pornography uh
gumblar spam a lot of the content is
there multiple times and you know I was
just telling you before oh you don't
want you know to upsample but if you end
up you know with the same page or the
same text repeated 10,000 times uh
that's probably not good so the quality
of web data out of the box is really bad
it's like the worst place you can start
from um but you know we are feeling
adventurous and so we decided to go on a
web data adventure and we saw that okay
let's make web data really good and we
build the tooling for this and G is
going to present you the pipeline that
we Built For This Cod macro dat
refinements yeah so I see
someone by the reaction uh so hi
everyone so we have all this data in
common crow which as Julian said is this
red we available a massive quantity of
web data and it is absolute trash we
have to clein this data we have to get
it ready so we can actually get
something usable as u a model so we
start with our you know our raw common
crow data so which is a lot and right in
the beginning we have a
decision uh which is do we want to use
the ACT uh the HTML version of common CW
because common CW gives this it
available in two different ways so you
have a version where you have the Raw
HTML content from websites that they
have extracted and you have a version
where they extract the content from this
website for you so the thing we decided
early on is that we didn't like this uh
Point text version so we wanted to roll
our own text extraction from HTML um
this ended up being the most expensive
step in our data processing pipeline so
one good thing we could do is before
doing this we could actually just look
at URL so this is how we start we start
by filtering the content we have based
on the actual URL we pulled um bunch of
um lists of websites that you should
block on things like schools and so on
and we use this word list to start by
filtering things like not safe forward
content uh some gambling content and so
on um so we could you know cheaply
filter down on things we don't want and
then we take our raw HTML content and we
use a python Library called Trail Aura
to extract the text from the qu what do
you mean by extract the text so we don't
want menus we don't want the shared post
related info all this stuff right we
just want the actual content of the
website um then obviously we're training
uh English language a large language
model so we wanted English content makes
sense so we used a fast Tex classifier
we basically took each sample we
identified the language of the majority
of the content in this sample and we
removed everything that was not English
out of this we already filtered down to
around like 50% of common C documents so
luckily for us English is over
represented in common CW which is good
and we call this refined web braw in
English we take this data and then we
apply some basic filtering so we have
taken the content from the the website
now we want to look at this content and
see is it actually something we want to
train our model with and for this we
took a bunch of theistic so these are uh
now quite common a few of them were
discussed in papers by the main we
training gopher so a few things you can
do we you can look at repetitive content
within the website so you have some spam
based like websites that are just trying
to spam keywords for search engine
optimization where they just have the
same thing over and over they have a
bunch of different paragraphs so you can
try to to see like you can check ratios
of lines andrs words and so on you can
check the ratio of for example lists
some websites we just see a list of
links so it's just bullet points all
over you can check things like the
actual you know how much of this qu is
actually even alpha numeric you have
have a bunch of different
nonalphanumeric symbols probably don't
want this sort of thing and because this
is not a perfect process especially the
HML extraction sadly we always ended up
with things like at the end of the
sample you have something like share
this comment uh like so we tried to this
is a bit this part was a bit labor
intensive we looked at a bunch of things
we're keeping we tried to identify what
was there we could you know surgically
remove and we Tred to remove all this
stuff from the uh mostly the fooder of
content with this we have our refined
web so this is our data set we call it
refined web filtered so this is uh about
50% of the previous one so you see the
the issue with this is that you think
okay we have a lot of data let's start
cutting but things actually go down
quite quickly um so this is something to
keep in
mind we then did something that was
probably the biggest boost afterwards
for model performance you'll see this
when Alandra tells you about the results
which was the duplication so as julan
said duplication is a big problem for R
language model especially as the size
increases so what we tried to do and we
were really really went the ex out here
was we want to make sure that the data
we are giving the model is as to the
best of our ability unique so you want
to make sure that you're not giving the
same uh exact text five 50,000 times and
if you just take the web you know
websites copy data from one place to the
other you have things like you know like
you have a word WordPress plugin that
has this uh you know whatever trademark
thing that is copied or licensed that is
copied all over the Internet so it is
really important for this we use two
main techniques so we use minhash
minhash is a method where you can try to
find similar documents it's a fuzzy
duplication method uh you basically look
at the content you try to find uh make a
signature for a document that is where
if two documents are similar the
signatures will also be similar and then
you try to identify documents you have
you make clusters of documents and we
had documents that would be repeated
basically like hundreds of thousands of
times um which is just a waste you
training a the model the gpus are very
expensive you're just giving it the same
thing over and over again and we removed
uh everything from each of these
clusters except for one document in each
cluster we then did a more uh thorough
um duplication method which is exact
substring so basically what you do is
you remove exact sequences that repeated
in the exact same uh manner word for
word in many different places and here
we remove them from all the documents we
could find for this sequence um some
previous work like minhash is quite
common when you're processing data for L
language models exact sub string is not
as common and especially merging these
two actually allowed us to scale better
because the scale of date we were
operating at is bigger than usual at the
time so we combined these two and this
gave us the final refined web so about
50 50% again of refined web filtered and
if we go back to the beginning it's
about 10% of uh everything in common CW
there was a an additional fourth stage
that we considered but we didn't end up
doing which is you can try to use
already some uh machine learning uh
methods to improve the data so this is
has been done by other models in the
past you can for example have a
reference data set such as Wikipedia and
try to compare documents to this you
know reference data set see if something
resembles Wikipedia you say okay this is
actually good we opted to not do this uh
this was a choice um and also we did not
try anything like trying to rules based
meth methods of you know this looks like
a conversation we actually want more
conversations let's extract this keep
this and remove other things uh so just
just as a this is just to be for
completion but you know the results
thater will tell you about do not
include um these two methods that we did
not use so here we have a breakdown of
everything we got at the end of this
entire process this is a big scary
figure uh just as a note the gray um
rectangles are in reference to the
previous step the colorful ones are just
in reference to the entire thing so you
can see as we just filtered URLs we
removed the tiny percentage about
2.2% we um did our language uh our text
extraction our language um
identification and we ended up with our
English data which as we said before is
about 50% you can see here is 47.
51% um then we started filtering right
so we went down and we did our document
wise filtering where we check if a
document is too repetitive if it a you
know ratios of words or of alpha numeric
characters whatever don't match what we
think they should match we keep removing
documents uh we are now 35% we have
removed 24 from the previous stage we
corrected a few lines this doesn't
remove much and then we have the
duplication which then just you know
takes whatever we have and just gives us
half of it um and really what we are now
experience running duplication at scale
was what really uh made a difference
between our data set and other data sets
so how big a difference the difference
was all this you'll hear from our Cent
now we'll tell you about the results we
got hello everyone um from Julian you
have
heard the why we have done it from G you
heard how we have done it and now uh I
will show you how we made sure that
actually we did the
the proper thing uh usually when people
do research on pre-training data sets uh
one of the thing that they do the most
is to check uh validation loss on varus
data sets we decided to not do that and
to check zero shot evaluation that's for
two reasons the first one is that
validation loss has been shown to be at
odds sometimes with the end task and the
second reason is that because we are
always training and looking at outo
aggressive decter only Transformers and
the most natural setting to evaluate
such an architecture is a zero shot so
we use the eii Arness and we use an
aggregate of task with a signal at three
between 1 and three billions par meter
that means that we did these experiments
at really low scale around one then we
scaled up to seven but the idea is to
have meaningful performance even at that
scale meaning that all the results are
far from random Baseline even at low
scale uh we have a core big science uh
aggregate of stask and then we have some
other Aggregates for the people who are
not familiar with uh NLP uh benchmarks
all of them are just like a little uh
like small data set where you evaluate
how good the model is to do some
specific things that can be a really
easy things like uh is it more likely
that uh if I say hello I'm speaking to
to a cat or a person things like that
that can be more sophisticated but many
of them are like uh really simple as to
evaluate the performance of the
model um how so we trained uh obviously
our own model and our own com B code
base uh on refined web and we compare to
uh other model of the same size trained
on the same amount of tokens and we
compare with the the results you can see
on the gbd3 paper for that size then we
have uh the same model through their API
on the openi website and then we check
with the other models trained by the big
science architecture and scale group and
as I already said obviously we already
we also trained our model uh on the pile
also on the pile so first thing you can
see that I find is really interesting is
that on the left you can see three
models same architecture trained on the
same amount of tokens on the same data
set and yet you have different uh
performances this is just an INT on why
sometimes it is hard to U you know
evaluate performance and this is just
because they've been trained on
different code bases the architecture is
always the Transformer but sometimes
they diff uh slight differences for
example the positional encoding and
obviously sometimes even if you have
trained on the same amount of tokens
maybe they were not the same tokens
there's always a bit of variability on
on that and on the uh so on the left on
the right you see the performance of
these models on the two Aggregates we've
mentioned we have external parm and
external uh big signs so this is the
performance of gpt3 this like it one
thing that is really important is to
understand how impossible was to achieve
the same performance for open source
model open source dat for a while like
literally this performance was so far
away that people start thinking that you
know at open a had some special special
recipe that was not like available to
the rest of the public and that's why
the results I'm going to show you is
really important this is you know uh is
the proof that everything you heard uh
about MDR macro dat requirement actually
worked and is important for a lot of
reasons one first reason it was really
important for us of course we did all of
the job and and it paid out but most
importantly you heard how important it
is to scale this architecture that we
actually able to get enough data like
the trend is that most people will keep
scaling these models and using data from
curated sources is not the solution it
doesn't scale as fast and I can tell you
that uh from a person that actually
spent quite a lot of time creating
specific data that can be archive can be
redit like really takes so much effort
to get a small amount of data at at
variance here we can see that just by
refining a snapshot of the web as messy
as it can be we can reach similar
performance to a uh curated data and
this is a result at 1.3 billion
parameters some of you may argue you
know like that's a really small scale if
you want to check the full experimental
setup there's more experiment on the
refined web paper sto short story short
uh the same result obviously they scale
up to 7 billion parameters on the paper
uh we we also show an ablation on why
for example the duplication as G said
was really important and then obviously
also the results of the 40 and 180b uh
models uh I think that was the final SL
so thank you very much and I guess qu
questions are welcomed from
everyone